we'll see why people like Andrew Tate
got such traction yes so what I've said
about Andrew Tate is that I would say
that 75 of Andrew takes diagnoses of the
problem are pretty correct yeah I agree
and then I would say that a lot of his
prescriptions are completely wrong yeah
right so so he will he will say men have
lost their role in the world and then
what he will model is cam girls it's
like well that's not actually the
solution but what you're saying about
the problem of men losing their role and
Men needing to be masculine and Men
needing to want to win and Men needing
to cultivate an ability to to go out and
succeed and thrive in the world all of
that is 100 true I just think that he
himself on a personal level wasn't
providing a model of that to me a model
of that is a guy who is married who has
kids who lives in the community who
better as the community lives in who
hires people creates a business like
these are the things that historically
speaking did Define manhood and now they
no longer Define manhood men I think
that you can chart at the moment of
deterioration for the moment James Bond
solid crying it's like you know you take
even that take even bonded emasculated
he has to be in touch with his feelings
why